[music playing]
[airplane engine]
RICHARD DOLAN: October 1, 1948,
you have an experienced World
War II pilot named
George Gorman, who's
out near Fargo, North Dakota.
He's flying a P-51 Mustang.
And as he's coming
back toward the base,
he sees this light
in the distance that
very rapidly zooms toward him.
And what ensues for the
next 27 to 30 minutes
is what we can only
call a dogfight.
JACQUES VALLEE: This
was one of the earliest
pilot cases that were well
described, well observed.
RICHARD DOLAN: What's also
interesting is that the Air
Force investigative
project, which back then
was called Project Sign--
this is 1948-- did
send investigators
out there to look into it.
J Allen Hynek, who's a
professional astronomer
with very excellent
scientific credentials.
He was working at
Ohio State University
and was contracted starting in
1948 to work with the Air Force
to provide astronomical
explanations for some
of their flying saucer reports.
PAUL HYNEK: My father
loved Air Force pilots,
because he said, how can the
Air Force deny reports by people
that they themselves trained?
RICHARD DOLAN: Years
later, a drawing
that Gorman made of the
encounter was declassified.
And it shows you've got an
experienced, seasoned World War
II fighter pilot, who's dealing
with a light phenomenon that
is clearly outperforming
his aircraft.
You've got a lot of witnesses
seeing this, one in the air--
another pilot--
and a number of
people on the ground,
including air
traffic controllers.
And it's a somewhat
mystifying event.
JACQUES VALLEE: The Air
Force ended up explaining it
as a combination of
looking at planet
Jupiter and a weather
balloon, which in retrospect,
does not make any sense.
And Hynek was very skeptical
of that explanation.